today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video so
quarantine fatigue is it's a real thing
and when I talk about quarantine fatigue
I'm not talking about the furious
gun-toting protesters that are demanding
states be haphazardly open back up even
when it's clear that states can't be
opened back up I when I talk about
quarantine fatigue like an adult I'm
talking to the other adults who have
been doing what the public health
officials are telling us we have to do
and who may be experiencing different
types of quarantine fatigue this can be
psychological this can be physical for
people who are just around less and
moving around less and it can of course
be economic which we've been talking
about as well the people in the
coronavirus is a hoax this is government
tyranny camp they're living in another
world that's not who I'm trying to
engage with here but I do think that
it's completely reasonable that by this
point if you're in one of the states
that is eight weeks in to stay at home
orders even even longer or close to it
in any case there is significant fatigue
that comes with self isolation and the
guidelines that we've been following and
I want to talk about a few different
things one is of course what we're doing
is to flatten the curve and we
understand that nobody's questioning
that piece and that's why we're doing it
when we go out we have to wear masks and
doors and in places where you can't stay
six feet away from people you're not
supposed to see friends and family that
you don't live with in many professions
you're either working from home if
you're lucky or you could be laid off or
or even permanently fired your business
may have closed for good but people can
only do it at a hundred percent for so
long and the question is becoming as
people become more fatigued what should
be done
clearly flipping a switch and going back
to the way things were would be a
disaster and we would undo a lot of the
progress that we've actually made in the
last four six eight or even nine weeks
that this has been going on
but maintaining things exactly as they
have been in the most closed States is
starting to approach an expiration date
so what should be done there's a really
good piece in the Atlantic which
explains if you just insist on keeping
everything as is keeping the strictest
quarantine it's sort of like abstinence
only sex education which we all know
doesn't work it's not realistic it does
not actually work the more reasonable
thing would be to be clear with people
and have better more detailed guidelines
about what people can do so let me talk
about the all along stuff and then the
moving forward all along it would have
been better to get federal guidance on
things that you should do for example go
outside 15 minutes every day a lot of
people they're not elite not even
stepping out of the door even if it's
your front step or your building's roof
or a backyard you know depending whether
you're urban rural whatever just about
everybody can step outside for 15
minutes and every week we're learning
more about the connection between
vitamin D and coronavirus we don't know
that it's causal we see a correlation
right now but it certainly won't help
I'm sorry it certainly won't hurt if
everybody gets 15 minutes of Sun every
day total vitamin D would be up fewer
people would be deficient mood improves
with sunlight and outdoors and risk is
very low if you can't step outside
without being six feet away from people
then you got to wear a mask great would
have been great to have clarity on that
earlier most of the transmission is
happening in doors between people living
together then you have transmission at
indoor workplaces and health facilities
then you have transmission at indoor
essential businesses right like grocery
stores etc very far down is transmission
from people outdoors of course if people
are responsibly crowd together on a
narrow hiking trail it's bad but the
transmission happening outside from
people passing each other on bikes this
type of stuff that that's been spreading
as if it's extremely dangerous it's not
zero but it is extraordinarily low and
think of the good of people getting
outside getting sunshine and hopefully
doing some exercise walking around etc
federal and state guidance on what are
considered low
versus high-risk activities would be
great for example and New York is now
doing this tennis versus basketball I
think I don't have to explain why
there's a dramatic difference there also
harm reduction tactics for people who
are determined that they are just gonna
do high-risk activities we are seeing
that a lot of people just don't listen
to the guidelines in any other public
health venue we would provide harm
reduction if you are going to inject
heroine we at least want to make sure
you have a clean needle so you're not
spreading HIV if you are going to be
sexually active we prefer you do it
safely and give people access to
contraceptives and sex education if you
are going to absolutely be doing an
activity like this or that here are the
things you absolutely must do to reduce
the risk now moving forward there are
governors that are managing the
psychological component of this better
than others I'll give you an example is
New York ready to open of course not the
numbers are dramatically improved but
the answer is they're not ready yet so
what is Andrew Cuomo doing the governor
there he announced three advancements so
to speak
yesterday number one so this is all
starting Friday landscaping and
gardening businesses will be allowed to
open these are businesses where workers
don't even have to interact with
customers it's outdoors this makes sense
and it is businesses that get to open
some people that get to go to work
that's a good thing outdoor low-risk
recreational activities like tennis
again being able to play tennis outdoors
but not basketball it makes sense
everyone's really close together in
basketball not so in tennis and Andrew
Cuomo is going to open or allow to open
drive-in movie theaters which of course
there aren't that many I don't think
there's any in New York City but
certainly a lot of New York state most
most of New York State is relatively
rural and I don't know the number of
drive-in theaters but it's an activity
and it is something that people can do
this is the type of thing that should be
done now because it adds almost no risk
but it builds capital because people
feel like something is going on now it
only works if people do the things they
need to do when they are doing these
different things Charlie Baker here in
Massachusetts
yesterday announced that they're going
to announce some first phase openings
that could happen as soon as next week
I assume it will be very minor low-risk
stuff but again the psychological
benefit will be very big blue states are
doing better at this than red states in
total red states have been either doing
the the stay-at-home order where people
are rebelling and it's imploding or
doing nothing and the virus is spreading
like wildfire that there actually is a
middle ground here it involves very low
risk activities harm reduction making
people aware that there are things they
could and even should be doing that are
going to be good for their mental health
and their physical health and get you
more buy-in and allow people to behave
safely for a longer period of time
hopefully we'll see more governors do
these types of things ok let's talk a
little bit about Tara Reid Tara Reid is
the woman who accused Joe Biden of
sexual assault now I'm not here to
evaluate her claims to play tit for tat
to debunk things I'm getting a lot of
emails from people saying David I need
you to go through the evidence did she
do it or didn't she did did she do it
meaning did she file the complaint or
didn't she file the complaint did Biden
do it or did he not do it I'm not able
to do that and nor do I think it's the
appropriate thing to do what I am here
to tell you is from a political
standpoint in terms of figuring out what
you're going to do in November if you
were someone who is debating what to do
in November on the basis of Tara Reid
situation there is never going to be a
conclusive investigation that tells us
what happened ok we you all need to
understand this and you're gonna have to
figure out what to do in November
without a conclusion from an
investigation and the reason that it's
not going to happen is that it
essentially cannot happen given what we
know I'm gonna explain what I mean in a
moment the reason this is important is
that a lot of people who don't like
Biden and don't like Trump are now
taking advantage of the Tara Reid story
to essentially not have to make a
decision about whether voting for Biden
is better than voting for Trump people
who clearly are on Biden side on the
issues or closer to Biden side than
Trump's on the
issues are insisting that until they
know the truth about what happened in
the 1990s until it's really investigated
they can't decide it's time to skip to
the end any investigation that takes
place based on what's been made
what allegations have been made so far
would not tell you whether this did or
did not happen it wouldn't this is not
just about he-said she-said although it
is this is not about believe women or
don't as I've said before making
allegations is very serious it exposes
the victim to harassment and shame and
the whole thing it must be taken
seriously when a victim makes an
allegation this is simply about all that
I'm talking about now is that there
could not possibly be based on
everything we know right now a
conclusive investigation there's a
bigger topic as well which is can
someone prove they did not commit a
sexual assault when the allegations
themselves are like the ones we have
here there's only a very narrow way that
you could prove you did not commit a
sexual assault and that would be like
imagine that Tara Reid filed a complaint
on a specific day and we saw oh the
allegation is that this supposedly took
place on this day and then Biden's
travel schedule from that time shows he
was out of the country okay maybe in
that narrow scenario you could conclude
he didn't do it but beyond that you
can't really prove you didn't commit
sexual assault and in this particular
case we can't even find the complaint
Biden said release certain records but
he hasn't said release others Tara Reid
doesn't have a copy of the complaint she
previously said the complaint was for
sexual assault now she says the
complaint she did file doesn't mention
sexual assault but it describes sexual
harassment but there's no copy of the
complaint so what I am Telling You is
not that she's telling the truth or that
she's lying we should take her
allegation seriously but there is not a
complaint to investigate Joe Biden
cannot prove his innocence nor is there
any way to confirm Tara Reid's
allegations there couldn't be a
conclusive investigate
now what about this idea that's floating
around that she was fired because of the
complaint that she filed it's such a
mess at this point that no investigation
could conclude anything she says she was
fired for filing the complaint we can't
find there's a negative performance
review on file whose timing can be used
to call this into question well what if
you go and talk to witnesses well Tara
Reid says she approached three Biden
aides about this back in the 90s all
three of those people told the New York
Times they don't know anything about it
could they have forgotten sure
could they be lying sure but the point
is it would be like the Cavanaugh
investigation where it is impossible to
conclude this happened or this didn't
happen given that there is no way that
an investigation would ever tell us
Biden did it or Biden didn't do it
the message is you're going to have to
decide whether you prefer Trump or Biden
to be President I think there are lots
of people who would love a way out of
voting for Joe Biden and would see Biden
did it as a bailout that they need to
feel okay about taking an action that
helps reelect Donald Trump listen the
DNC screwed itself they selected a
sexual-assault er they lost my vote but
that investigation is not going to
happen and you're going to have to
decide on the issues now does any of
this clear bide and of course not
there's almost no way Biden could be
cleared again if it was determined that
on the day Tara Reid claims this
happened Biden was in China that might
clear him but you'd still have people
say oh I'm sure Tara Reid just doesn't
remember the right date if the
investigation determined as almost every
single one of these do that it cannot
find evidence to confirm Tara Reid story
nor can it find evidence to disprove
Tara Reid story people will read that as
whatever they want either it happened
but there's not enough evidence maybe
because the evidence was suppressed
people will come up with that or people
will say see I told you there's no
evidence that this thing happened it
doesn't matter in the end because you
are going to need to decide given that
there will never be such a conclusion
you will need to decide what is better
for the country
in November I'm not going to evangelize
my point of view you all know the
calculation I've made you are going to
have to make the same calculation
without the benefit of a conclusive
investigation which there will never be
there may be an investigation there is
no way given what we know that it would
be conclusive and give you the answer
many of you are waiting for you disagree
let me know i'm on twitter at depatment
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue to calm and use promo code David
you will get your first shipment
completely free just pay $5 shipping
that's promo code David you get your
first shipment of blue two completely
free and I've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are Brian Lindbergh and Tom has
arouse key thanks to Brian and Tom and
also thanks to the set Tyrell who's
today's longtime sustaining member of
the day grab a membership support the
show at join pakman.com I'm gonna come
clean with you guys I'm sick of being
laughed at even though I didn't vote for
the guy I'm sick of being the
laughingstock on this planet the entire
planet is laughing at us making fun of
us we are the punchline of every global
political joke because of Donald Trump
now his followers may not know or they
may not care Trump may keep telling
himself and us that we are the envy of
the world including on our handling of
coronavirus and testing and everything
else but it's not true and I am really
embarrassed by it because it's shameful
to be this laughingstock the whole world
thinks were a joke because Trump is a
joke and Appelbaum are rights that in
China the official Chinese news agency
is pushing videos making fun of us
claims by Donald Trump that it's only a
flu claims that are embarrassing to go
back and look at today that video has
gone viral in Indonesia they wrote in
disbelief about Trump proposes
disinfectant injection and UV rays to
treat Kovan 19 in France reports say the
rantings of dr. Trump ridiculing him
once again in South Africa an article
promotes the horrors of u.s. President
Donald Trump leaving people stunned and
confused with his bizarre suggestion
that disinfectant and ultraviolet light
could be used to treat the virus in Peru
a newspaper article called attention to
dr. deborah birx 'as visibly pained
expression as trump wondered aloud about
bleach injections to treat corona virus
and meanwhile as the world laughs Trump
insists everybody looks up to us and
buddy looks up to him on coronavirus and
testing and everything we're doing here
is Trump at a recent event making this
case and we're going to do a job like
like nobody's seen before and I spoke
with Angela Merkel today I spoke with
Prime Minister Abbey of Japan I spoke
with many of the leaders over the last
four or five days and so many of them
almost all of them I would say all of
them not everybody would want to admit
it but they ovo us as the world leader
and they're following us you look at
what we've done with ventilators we
started this is one of two things either
a clueless person saying something that
they believed to be true which is not
which is obviously not true or it's
gaslighting it is making someone believe
it is making someone question the
reality by telling them something that
is completely disconnected from fact if
any of them are looking to us if other
countries are looking to the United
States it's to avoid doing what we did
because almost every country has handled
coronavirus better than we have Russia
now is becoming a mess it's a mess in
Russia and they're rapidly becoming one
of the epicenters Russia maybe handle
this worse than the United States we
don't know yet it's early brazil is
becoming a major cesspool of coronavirus
transmission we know about John Bolson
arroz skeptical attitude towards the
virus India is growing Lee growing a
problem not growing Lee is increasingly
a problem when it comes to the virus
we'll see if they are able to turn it
around but otherwise everybody would be
looking to us to not do what we've done
they're not impressed with us we're not
the leader here they're laughing at us
now there's a new report which says it's
actually worse than just laughter
laughter would be one thing there's a
new report that says the world is
actually despairing because countries
that have become used to seeing the us
at the table figuring out solutions now
we're seeing the u.s. as completely
useless because of Donald Trump European
critics say it's not just that Trump
isn't helping like the United States
normally does Trump is a row
respect for the United States and
getting in the way of global cooperation
and solutions this has real-world
implications and I want to be clear
about that this is not a haha Trump
segment our global position is being
destroyed by this man electing Trump in
2016
instantly called into question the u.s.
as being a serious country but maybe it
was a mistake
if Trump is reelected it will cement the
United States as a joke and there's no
other way to say it
if that happens we are going to have to
face the reality that American voters
are as much of a problem as Trump
himself and the people Trump hires now
we've suspected this for a while we've
talked about it for a while but it will
be the the last confirmation if we
reelect Donald Trump we will know that
the disaster actually afflicts 60 maybe
even 70 million people who may vote for
Trump in November of 2020 the world is
laughing a lot of people actually take
pleasure in that Trump ascared our
reputation around the world or they
simply tell themselves our reputation is
great but this is not good and it must
be stopped
Donald Trump abruptly raged quit his own
press briefing yesterday after a
historically embarrassing implosion even
by Trump's own standards I've
essentially stopped covering the press
briefings and the roundtables and the
propaganda events on the podcast than
the broadcast show because they're just
trash I mean there's simply
disinformation there's no news they are
worthless at communicating policy in any
significant way they've also been going
on a lot less frequently ever since
Trump wondered aloud about injecting
bleach to treat coronavirus but
yesterday Trump scheduled one and it is
really worth telling you what happened
I'm going to skip right to the questions
part the presentation I can sum up as
we're the best on testing and the envy
of the world
with that out of the way let's get to
the questions we're gonna start with the
build-up about Obama Gate will go to the
climax where Trump tells an Asian
reporter to ask China and then the day
knew mom we're Trump of
rapidly walks off furious that a CNN
reporter tried to ask a question so
we'll start with Philip Rucker Philip
his White House bureau chief at The
Washington Post also wrote a book that
very much triggered Donald Trump called
the very stable genius
Rucker is really good at framing
questions in a way that directly exposed
Trump's non answers Trump's been
tweeting about so-called
Obama gait Trump tweeted it in all caps
with no explanation over the weekend
also claiming that the Obama
administration and Obama himself
committed the biggest political crime in
American history here is Philip Rucker
expertly asking Trump which crime did
Barack Obama commit what law did he
break Trump glitches freezes and simply
repeats Obama Obama gate is the crime
take a look mr. president in one of your
Mother's Day tweets you appear to accuse
President Obama of the biggest political
crime in American history by far those
were your words
what crime exactly are you accusing
President Obama of committing and do you
believe the Justice Department should
prosecute him Obama game it's been going
on for a long time it's been going on
from before I even got elected and it's
a disgrace that it happened and if you
look at what's gone on and if you look
at now all of this information that's
being released and from what I
understand that's only the beginning
some terrible things happened and it
should never be allowed to happen in our
country again Obama gate is the crime my
friends now Philip Rucker tries to
follow up of course now I looked at the
US code of law I couldn't find Obama
gate as a crime because it doesn't exist
Trump has no idea what he's talking
about here's the follow-up from Philip
Rucker and you'll be seeing what's going
on over the next over the coming weeks
but and I wish you'd write honestly
about it but unfortunately you choose
not to do so yeah gently what if the
crime exactly like you think you know
what the crime is the crime is very
obvious to everybody what you have to do
is read the newspapers except yours John
please this is a child ladies and
gentlemen this is a child so next let's
go the CBS News reporter Wei Jia Jiang
friend of the show also extremely
proficient at get
Trump to blow his stack she asks why are
you always bragging about testing like
why whether it's true or not why is this
a competition when people are dying
people continue to die and Trump doesn't
like it he flips out and says why don't
you go ask that question to China
yeah go ahead please many times that the
u.s. is doing far better than any other
country when it comes to testing yes why
does that matter
why is this a global competition to you
if everyday Americans are still losing
their lives and we're still seeing more
cases every day well they're losing
their lives everywhere in the world and
maybe that's a question you should ask
China
don't ask me has China that question
okay when you ask them that question you
may get a very unusual answer yes behind
you please so this already makes no
sense before we even get to the Asian
component of it the question was why is
this a competition on testing while
people died he says go ask China ask
them what I don't hear the Chinese
president saying we have the most and
best tests or we've defeated the
invisible scourge but then it gets
really wild when we Jia Jiang who is
Asian says why are you asking me to go
talk to China what why me what sir why
are you saying that to me specifically
I'm telling you I'm not saying it
specifically to anybody I'm saying it to
anybody that would ask a nasty question
like that please go ahead okay anybody
else so is this something about Wei Jia
Jiang being asian-american I don't know
with Trump you never know but it's all
just wacky it's cartoonish it's a comedy
of errors and this really has Trump
riled for the last bit of it
the last pillar of the three-headed
monster for Trump or the equivalent of
Trump's kryptonite when being asked
questions is made up of Phillip Rucker
Wei Jia Jiang and lastly CNN's Caitlyn
Collins she gets up to ask a question
Trump called on her right before weigh
Jia Jiang's follow-up I guess she didn't
react quickly enough by allowing wage
via to follow up and Trump rage quits
and walks out of the room or back into
the White House better said okay anybody
else please go ahead in the back place
it's okay y'all I had two questions this
direction next place but you didn't you
called on me I did and you didn't
respond and now I'm calling on the young
lady in the back please ladies and
gentlemen thank you very much appreciate
it
thank you very much I can't tell if at
the end there you hear someone say what
or if that's something else but what a
moment what what an implosion and this
is why he's been cutting the briefings
because they're an increasingly
embarrassing disaster imagine any other
president Republican or Democrat
ragequitting after acting this
childishly so the way Jia Jiang part the
caitlin collins part these are more
about trumps wacky behavior he's clearly
very afraid of caitlin collins asking
questions okay the really crucial part
here is Trump claiming Obama perpetrated
a crime president's accusing former
presidents of crimes is a big deal being
asked what crime was committed is
logical and being unable to say this is
what the crime was is particularly
problematic now you may surmise that
there's no evidence that Obama committed
a crime that Donald Trump is trying to
accuse him of Trump is clearly desperate
to take attention off of the virus and
instead go after Obama for something
anything and we've got to watch this
very closely because we've seen Trump's
Justice Department say they're not gonna
prosecute a guy who pleaded guilty
Michael Flynn they are now emboldened
and they're liable to really be out
there with this Obama crime stuff so
we'll keep following it including on our
Instagram account make sure you are
following the David Pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show and while
you're there with peace and love follow
me on instagram as well I am David
Pakman on instantly
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com the david pakman show depends
on your support and the easiest way is
through membership which includes the
world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show it's great to
welcome back to the program our old
friend Bill share contributing editor to
Politico magazine contributor to Real
Clear Politics
and an ardent follower of the ins and
outs of election years in particular
although you know you're not just an
election year guy you're in year and
year out but things are getting more
interesting unless I have many many
gears David yes of course
so I mean listen just to start with what
is the trajectory for the next 5 and 1/2
months it's like is this election going
to happen in person is it going to be
vote-by-mail will it depend on state by
state people are talking about Trump
will try to delay it but he will fail I
just have no idea how to even think of
the next five and a half months well
think he can't delay it he does not the
power to delay it Congress would never
agree to delay it that won't happen to
the extent we're voting by mail probably
gonna be pretty patchwork state-by-state
some states will do a better job and get
ahead of the curve some states will drag
their feet and you know what that means
at the end of the day is hard to project
and as far as to what extent this whole
pandemic is going to matter you know
it's obviously a big wild card but
consider this we are in May
we've already had in 2020 an impeachment
a ongoing pandemic and economic collapse
and a sexual assault allegation at the
Democratic nominee presumptive as well
not to mention of course the past's
allegations to become president and the
numbers haven't moved very much
you know Biden has had a fairly stable
lead in the real Clear Politics average
generally between five and seven now
just on this past Friday in a tick down
to four point four that might be a
little statistical noise or it could be
a two-week Soutar read coverage as you
know brought down a little bit but you
go back to the fall such as to September
of 2019
by it has never been below four in the
in his average lead-in RCP and that is
different than Hillary Clinton people
get people keep saying Oh Hillary was
ahead in the polls so is by it in you
can't trust that and look things can
change I'm not saying Biden's a lock but
their numbers are different Hillary had
dipped several times going below 4 into
a near tie or an actual tie couple of
times even slightly behind between
September 2015 an election day and in
May of 2016
she had a big dip she some people were
saying Biden bite it was worse than
Hillary in April yeah Hillary was
peaking in April April was when she was
ceiling she was putting burning away and
there were some buyer's remorse on Trump
and Cruz is winning some primaries May
was when Trump locked it down Bernie's
still dogging Hillary and the FBI
investigation on the email servers was
really cranking up and she went from you
know we're on nine points to a tie by
the end of the month now she got she
bounced back up
she was volatile she was bouncing up and
down not like every week but some byte
has not done that much at all he had a
narrowing with Purisima at the turn of
the year which got him down to four
moved back up into five and seven now
he's a little closer to four as of today
but it's not like Terry it is becoming
you know I'm the president
in the media so I wouldn't think that
would keep following the way Hillary did
with the email server investigation yeah
I want to talk about the Tara Reid thing
in a moment now one of the things in
2016 you hear this talking point the
polls were just wrong now I think it's
important when we look at that to say in
terms of the popular vote the polls were
essentially correct of course we have an
electoral college system and you can
find three states were about
seventy-five thousand votes push the
electoral college over to trump that to
me seems I mean I know there's these
hypotheticals where you could win the
electoral college with 27% of the
popular vote we've never seen that and
it would have to be a crazy situation in
practice is three points of popular vote
difference roughly the most that could
still see the electoral college go the
other way and to put it a different way
if Biden wins the popular vote by five
wouldn't it be incredibly like one in a
million that he would lose the electoral
college I mean some of our beta better
data journalists like Dave Wasserman
like Nate cone or earlier earlier this
year late last year we're making the
case that Trump could win by five Trump
could lose popular vote by five points
or more
yes and still win the electoral college
there are ways that can happen based on
how the demographics play out
however those projections were made
before we saw Biden's demographics
Biden's demur graphics are not Hillary's
demographics Biden does better much
better with seniors then Hillary did and
Obama did you look at Hillary and
Obama's numbers generationally it's a
diagonal line downward the older you get
the less democratic you are Biden's kind
of a V I think it's kind of soft around
middle age around Gen X and early
boomers and they comes back up with 65
and over and so that may make a
difference in states with senior
populations like Florida like Arizona so
and what we see today at least when we
see Biden you know around four to seven
and most polls Mohamed was
nine that was kind of high in CNBC was
three
there was one tie which was the
investor's business daily
but generally five to seven state polls
in this same period very good for Biden
winning in Florida winning in Arizona
winning in the industrial Midwest
there's even one where he was even up in
Texas another one was a tie yeah so it's
not getting not a lock these are not
like massive leads that can't evaporate
based on circumstances in the future but
you are seeing Biden doing well in the
swing states while winning in the
popular vote by around 5:00 or so so
Tara Reid my sense of this situation is
there cannot possibly be what we would
call a conclusive investigation in into
the allegation said I'm going to talk
more about this on the program tomorrow
but to not do my segment tomorrow now
the the gist of it is you've got a
he-said she-said situation the complaint
that Tara Reid says she filed but
doesn't mention sexual assault she
doesn't have a copy of and it's not
clear what the date is so I guess what
I'm saying is without criticizing or
even evaluating the truth of the claims
there's not enough to conclusively
determine what happened and thus
something I don't know what that
something is
I just think there's a lot of people
wanting something conclusive which
they're never going to get what's your
sense of it well I won't put myself in
the position of being the adjudicator
what's true or what's not of course
right that's the thing I don't think
we're gonna be able to let me just try
to talk about this in the terms of I
think the reaction amongst Democrats yes
and the reaction in the media okay Biden
gave a response a week plus ago that
went over well with elected Democrats
you did not see any elected Democrats
criticize him you didn't see anyone say
take me out the ring for VP you didn't
see the endorsement stop coming you saw
Democrats repeat his messages he gave a
statement which other Democrats felt
comfortable echoing Democrats don't
always do that that's it
thing so number one he kept this party
in line with that number - I think Tarr
Reid has made some PR mistakes again
this is not a this is not a bear on
whether it's true or not you like you
can be you could be telling the truth
and make PR mistakes but I think it was
a mistake to not respond to Biden
quickly you know she canceled on Fox she
canceled on CNN so there and so that
created like a three four-day period
where some media coverage were poking
holes in the story and she wasn't
responding and even though this might
have gotten wide pick up the Vox
recounting of what Tara Reid said there
actually - there was an AP story and a
spock story that got into what she said
in 2019 to reporters that wasn't
published at the time and contrasting
that with what was said today and not
just her but also one of her anonymous
corroborate errs and the 2019 substance
and tone was not sexual you know what I
wasn't scared by him he wasn't gonna
take me in a room wasn't that kind of
vibe the friends saying that he never
kissed her it just as a totally
different tone and context to what was
being said today and clearly that's had
resonance in media circles as well as
Democratic circles where they're not as
inclined to take Watari to saying a
straight face value without adding in
these mitigating elements so what you
find is megyn kelly a decision to do a
you know kind of a big name but not on a
TV platform on an online platform you
didn't see like if she did a scene an
exclusive that gets looped on scene and
all day long ya know whatever whatever
you think of the veracity of it it's
just it's gonna get repeated and
repeated and repeated you debating you
discuss it that didn't happen with megyn
kelly so all the stuff about Biden side
of the story and the questions of tar
Reid story that had time to settle
and that did not get reversed by the
megyn kelly interview is your sense that
in six weeks this will be a bigger part
of the race or a smaller part of the
race it's gonna be I think largely a
non-factor unless another shoe drops I
mean yeah who could have known that she
had a neighbor that she spoke to in 1986
you know come out of nowhere you know
somebody that happens sure things could
change but of course someone accuses him
of making a verbal sexual harrassment to
a 14 year old and it's debunked in 24
hours so you know what comes out of the
woodwork and doesn't hold up to scrutiny
you know that's those are things that
are gonna matter whether this keeps
going now I could see regardless of what
happens going forward Donald Trump doing
social media stuff targeting younger
people targeting women trying to plant
seeds of doubt you know semi under the
radar and see if you can hurt by it on
the margins he to this stuff with
Hillary you know very successfully but
that was a close race that stuff works
at a close race if it's not a close race
I don't think that stuff matters
so before the pandemic really got going
I had kind of a sense that in large part
November would be a lot about the
perception of the state of the economy
that's not any particularly unique
insight that that's it would just it
would just be that as it often is and
that's what made me think that polling
aside it was going to be very very
difficult to remove Donald Trump in
November with the completely failed
handling of the pandemic I started to
think maybe this is going to affect the
trajectory now a political scientists
Rachel bitter Kaufer a couple weeks ago
said she doesn't really think that
that's going to make a difference and I
want to try to parse through the idea of
maybe the handling of the pandemic
itself is baked in in the sense that
Trump's followers think he's doing fine
with it and a whole bunch of other
people don't believe that he's handled
it well but that that's not necessarily
going to change too many votes but isn't
that directly linked to the economy at
this point in the sense that isn't the
perception of the economy in
october/november going to relate
directly to what happens with the virus
sure and you know I
Rachele bit of copper a lot I've been a
sorcerer of my pieces I think she's
great I generally agree in a more a
political science view then perhaps a
campaign operative you a political
science you is generally look at the
fundamentals the stuff that campaigns do
tends to not have that much of an impact
at the end of the day at best on the
margins
I generally subscribe to that but this
is a bit unchartered territory you know
for example a political scientist might
say second quarter GDP is highly
determinative of the outcome if you're
on the rise people feel good about the
economy
you know GDP numbers tend to kind of
filter through over time so how you how
it feels on the ground you know you
don't feel it right away so what happens
in the second quarter
you'll feel by Election Day and that's
why that tends to have a correlation and
so if you are on a downward trend by the
second quarter
even if things are statistically picking
up by November you don't feel it yet
like George Bush in 1992 and so that
doesn't help you let me explore that
just briefly because the timing so
people understand second quarters April
May June it typically takes about 35
days to get the numbers so we would know
around August 5th or 10th
I think what the second quarter GDP
numbers were if they are indeed minus 20
is some are predicting you're talking
about a period starting in mid-august
which is actually much closer to the
election that then the second quarter
itself right it would it would seem
highly likely second quarter GDP will be
disastrous yeah and so you might punch
that into a model and say it's a done
deal where I would pause is say this is
a little different than your usual
recession or depression yes maybe the
virus lifts by September and people
start shopping more robustly in October
and even though these statistics haven't
caught up to that you're feeling better
and your opinion of Trump is better now
I'm not saying I think that's a high
probability scenario I think it's what
we're likely this virus doesn't go away
at all and we're still stuck at her
homes for our extended period of time
yeah but that's the kinda thing that I
can't say with certainty but the bottom
line is do you feel you're we're getting
better we're getting worse and I'm not
sure we can use current numbers to know
that because this is such a highly
unusual situation yeah my message to my
audience has simply been I don't care
what state you vote in I don't care what
the polls say I don't care what the past
tells us about what happens when the
economy is bad improving whatever we
just really don't know and if you care
about removing Donald Trump just make
sure that you vote and get ten other
people to vote however you can do it
because it's just so unpredictable well
that's right
now at any time an election is gonna be
close that kind of GOTV can really
matter right
you know Wisconsin Michigan pens me they
came down to a handful of votes one
campaign is maybe a little bit better
than the other yep that changes the
whole election now if we're in a
situation where the country's we decided
this Trump thing did not work that was a
bad idea
his multitude of ways and Biden's up by
you know seven points or whatever you
know getting five more your friends
doesn't matter I'm not saying you
shouldn't do it let's say you should
take take a nap on Election Day but I
think Super Tuesday is relevant here I
mean then I talked with us in a
political article today Super Tuesday
was this fantastic real time Poli Sci
experiment what's more important is it
paid media who owns the airwaves is it a
ground game which is often fueled by a
lot of online organizing these days or
is it free media Michael Bloomberg owned
pay media he just crushed paid media up
and down kept flooded the airwaves
Bernie had the ground game he had the
online he had he had the door-knocking
he had the small donor army and all that
stuff Biden was broke by it had no field
offices there were states he didn't even
visit but his free media
from Saturday to Tuesday was as golden
as has ever been and it wasn't just that
it was good it was communicating a
message that Democrats wanted to hear
who was electable who's in a govern in a
sound insane way who's gonna unify the
party that all came together in that
silly two-hour period anyone going away
with some endorsements in that pin that
period as well well but it's not like
people who did I mean most endorsements
don't matter right you know Al Gore did
not save Howard Dean correct the
endorsements communicated a message
yeah it was a very narrow scenario where
they actually made a difference yes
because it's not like people judge had
that many votes to give never clover
chard that many votes to give or better
or Orca that many votes to give but
there were people from different slices
of the Party although generally on the
moderate side of things saying hey if
you if you're not on for revolution if
you thought if you want a more moderate
pragmatic choice you could unify the
part of the country you have one option
and it's not Michael Bloomberg it's not
me Pete it's not me Amy it's this guy
and there were enough Democrats who
liked that message to come consolidate
around him without the benefit of a
strong campaign apparatus so if the
message in November is Trump is doing a
terrible job and Biden is a sane
competent alternative
you're not going need massive digital
operations or fantastic advertising to
win the election it's just gonna be
baked in the fundamental dynamics of the
electorate bill scher contributing
editor to political magazine contributor
to Real Clear Politics will link to his
the latest article that he referred to
bill always a pleasure having you on it
talk to you as well take care the David
Pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
I've got a great little lesson for all
of you today in historical revisionism
and gas lighting put together you might
be familiar with Cayley Mackin Annie
she's Donald Trump's latest press
secretary she has done a few press
briefings lying regularly for Donald
Trump she says that Trump is the best
president ever she justifies anything he
does and says she's the epitome of a
true brown-nosing sycophant but she was
not always like this
as far as Trump is concerned because
back during the 2016 Republican primary
she said Trump is hateful and says
racist things we have the video let's
take a look at it how sick of polls are
people in New Hampshire right now
probably very sick especially when they
see that Donald Trump is number two and
doesn't deserve to be there the GOP
doesn't need to be turning away voters
on isolating them we need to be bringing
them into the tent Donald Trump is the
last person who's going to do that Haley
this is your guy he's number two in the
polls hey I don't want to claim this guy
the fact that the Republican Party is
now having to claim him it's both
unfortunate and to me inauthentic what's
the expiration date then on a racist
statement to me a racist statements a
racist statement I don't like what
Donald Trump said I don't like what el
Sharpton says and at what point does it
expire and become something that BK
Trump is racist Trump is hateful she
doesn't like it she doesn't like him now
here's the real payoff Caylee was asked
about these past statements by reporter
Jimmy SH Alcindor during a recent press
briefing and her answer is the epitome
of an Orwellian look the other way sort
of answer she says you know I mistakenly
thought Trump was racist because I was
reading CNN headlines at the time this
is her explanation take a look at it and
in 2015 shortly after the presidency
it's so messy new immigrants are rapists
and criminals you said that that
language was racist and hateful do you
still believe that today well I'm
actually glad you asked that because for
about first four weeks of the election I
was watching CNN and I was naively
believing some of the headlines that I
saw on CNN and I'm actually not going to
read the headline so I very quickly took
came around supported the president in
fact CNN hired me I was on many eight on
one panels where I proudly supported
this president who I believe is one of
the best presidents it's not the best
president this country will ever have
but I would encourage the individual who
did that analysis of my past rather than
focusing on me he really should be
focused on some of the very guests and
shows to have on their network he should
be focused on I mean my over here Jim
Jim clapper who said you know ten days
before he privately told investigators
there was no evidence of collusion okay
so her notes for this question include
attacks on CNN guests and we can stop it
right there her argument is when I said
what I said about Donald Trump when I
said he was a hateful racist and all
that stuff i was wrong because i fell
for CNN headlines i no longer fall for
CNN headlines like i did back then how
easy to trick her though right can she
really be trusted if she so easily fell
for supposedly fake headlines from CNN
and do we trust her judgment if she took
a job with CNN as she says despite
believing that they are fake news now I
really need you to understand something
Trump is see that and they think it
makes sense trumpets are thrilled with
Caylee Mackin Annie they're gleefully
cheering how she's been owning the media
with these huge alpha take downs of the
biased fake news press corps it is
literal nonsense which only calls into
question her own judgment if she fell
for supposedly fake headlines and the
trumpets love it they regularly tweet
about how Caylee Mackin Annie is just
crushing these reporters during press
now on principle this explanation is
absurd but of course it's not just about
headlines she came up with these
opinions on her own it's not that she
was repeating things like I know you all
know that it's a dumb explanation but
she was coming up with stuff on her own
that was the anti-trump I'll give you an
example on August 6th of 2015 she
tweeted everyone seems to have a plan
except Trump live during a Republican
primary debate she didn't get that from
CNN that's her opinion she came up with
that she volunteered it so do I think
for a second that Caylee Mackin Annie
truly believes Trump is the best
president in history I don't believe it
for a second do I think she's willing to
say anything at any time in order to
justify her own career and try to
advance her own interests which right
now includes impressing Donald Trump and
having this national platform of press
briefings of course and every time she
tweets every time she speaks to the
press that's exactly what she's doing
and then maybe most importantly is it
working and the answer is on trumpets it
is trumpets are hugely impressed with
her every time she does one of these
joke press briefings Don junior retweets
it and talks about it a whole bunch of
people even people that are only sort of
tangentially involved in politics that I
know who are friends with on Facebook
and a sort of centrist right have been
posting clips of Caylee Mackin Annie and
how great and amazing everything she's
doing is it's concerning it's extremely
concerning because she seems to be
convincing the exact people that needed
to feel like here's someone who can
actually hold their own given that Trump
can't
during these press briefings and Caylee
Mac and Annie is doing it for them again
the world is laughing we on the left
think it's absolutely crazy what she's
doing but the people she's trying to
impress seem impressed very much so we
have a voicemail number that number is
two one nine to david p here is a caller
who well i'll just let her say it
i don't need to tell you too much about
it take a listen hey david and just
watch
the video about Trump tweeting over 52
times in one hour and was very much
reminded of my mother-in-law before she
was officially diagnosed with dementia
would all family members up to 100 times
a day leaving voicemails are talking to
them because she literally forgot that
she had called us and part of me in this
absolutely worried and this would be
horrible but it really reminds me of
that and makes me think that this could
possibly be a sign of dementia that he's
not remembering all these tweets that
he's given within an hour and it just
really reminds me of that thanks so much
yeah so I mean of course you know I'm
not qualified to say anything about a
dementia diagnosis but what you're
talking about with memory is interesting
and there's a couple things I would I
would put out there number one there are
times when reporters quote Trump's own
tweets to him and he certainly doesn't
seem to remember them his answer doesn't
indicate he actually remembers the
content of the tweet but that just may
be how Trump answers questions okay
that's one thing there are reports from
people inside the White House not
authorized to speak about this that say
Trump doesn't remember he just doesn't
remember he doesn't remember
conversations he's had with people he
essentially arguing that one of the
explanations that maybe is not getting
enough attention when Trump appears to
be lying or saying that he didn't say
something that he's on record saying is
that he genuinely has no memory of it so
this is not the first time that such an
allegation has been made on today's
bonus show very exciting I am going to
give you a prepping update I have a
number here in my home studio I have
received via the mail a number of
elements of prepping that I've ordered
some which are obviously beneficial some
which I have questions about so I'm
going to talk about that a little bit on
today's bonus show we will also talk
about 2,000 former Department of Justice
and FBI officials who are calling on
William Barr to resign for his handling
of the Michael
case we will talk about murder Hornets
so-called
and we will also talk about the Supreme
Court appearing as though they are going
to give religious employers a pretty
broad-based ability to discriminate all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get instant access by signing
up at join pakman.com or by making a
pledge of at least five bucks a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
we'll see you on the bonus show or on
the live streams or on tomorrow's
program appreciate you joining me today
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue chicom and use the promo code david
i've put a link right underneath this
video